خلود ابو بكر اسمهن سرعان محتل مواقع
البحث واكتسح مواقع تواصل السودان لذلك
بعد مشاركه مقطع فيديو للممثله السودانيه
من مسلسل زوجان ولكن والذي تقوم ببطولته
ظهر فيه عن طريق الخطا اجزاء من جسدها في
احد اللقطات المشهد اثاره هجوما ضد
الممثله خلود ابو بكر
واصل الاجتماعي في السودان اللقطه حيث
اتهم بعضهم ممثله بالاساء للمراه
السودانيه وبعد الضجه الكبيره التي اثارها
المشهد اقدمه الممثله السودانيه خلود ابو
بكر على الاعتذار عن ما بدر منها وطلبت من
الجميع مسامحتها ومسح مقطع الفيديو الذي
انتشر بكثافه حيث دخلت في نوبه بكاء
متابعه
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
انا عامله الفيديو ده حابين وانا اشكم
اي دول اتكلم فيني كلمه كلمه شكرا
العمل
حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل
انا ما عندي حذف يلا بنات سبحانه وتعالى
الحمد لله وانا بعتذر بس المشهد كان غير
مخصوص
واي زوجته في المشهد هيكون شافوني مشهد
عادي لكن هو كان انسان مريض عمل زومبي
العربيه شكرا لك
ادخلود السلام عليكم صباح الخير
صوره مشتاقه لك من المشهد تمثيلي اثارت
جدلا في السودان اولا نسمع منك انت ما
الذي حصل
انه انا بمثل في مسلسل اسمه زوجان ولكن
للاسف اذا اخذت لقطه من المسلسل ودعاء تم
التعامل معها بطريقه غلط
وانت شلطته اخذت لواط بصول هايله جدا
حصل بعض التنمر وبعد الاسعافات لكن الحمد
لله على كل حال يعني لحد الان احنا ما
عارفين العمل
ليه عمل كده لكن انا ما بقدر اقول غير انه
هو شخص
طب خلود خليني بس انا هيك يعني افهم منك
لما انت بتطلعي بفيديو
وتعبري فيه عن اسفك وتعتذري للجمهور اليس
هذا اعتراف ضمني منك بانه في خطا ما وانك
كانه عم بتجاري هذا الموجه وموجه
الانتقادات اللي عمالها تطالب
اا صلاح حسن
انه انا استلتي زي اي اس لمحافظه
لايف عشان اوضح سبب الحاجه اللي حصلت
معايا انه ما غلطي وانا ما كنت على دلايه
بها وان وانا ما اتصلحت على المشهد قبل
العرض
وطلبت من الناس اللي بتحبني انه تخفف شويه
الهدوم لانه انا عندي اسره
من الموضوع ده
فالناس بدات في اللايف يعني تضغط عليه
فانطه بالبكاء
بعديها بفتله بعد التضامن اللي حصل من
كثير من الناس انا بحب اشكلهم ااه قمت
عملت المقطع بتاع الفيديو ده شكله الناس
اللي وقفت جنبيه وقلت للشخص اللي عمل كده
لانه انا بافوت امر الله سبحانه وتعالى
سمكه يعني ما كانت الحاجه دي مقصود منها
انه انا اختلف بخطا او كده لا بس انا شكلت
الناس واعتزلتها اذا بدل حاجه
طيب اين كان القائمون عن العمل كيف سمحوا
بلقطه مثل هذه ان تطلع الهواء يعني تطلع
في العمل
اه
والله المقطع هو مش بلاك لكن معمول يعني
في وقتيها
اضافه ببعض الاشعه البسيطه اللي هي
اضافه بعض الاشياء البسيطه فالغيمون على
العمل يعني طلعوا وضحوا الحاجه دي انه هم
ملكت دي بالذات حتى الحاجه ركزوا عليها
الاداء بتاعي تعبان والله اكثر هي كانت
كسله من الثانيه فما انتبه لها هو غلط
بسيط
وان شاء الله
خلود من وقت ما طلع على هالخبر وانا بلاش
اعمل بحث يعني على جوجل على اسمك يعني اسم
خلود ابو بكر يقترن باسم فضيحه هل برايك
استغلت وسائل الاعلام هذه القضيه يعني
والصحافه الصفراء لانه انا حتى اليوم حتى
الان ما زلت ابحث عن هذه الفضيحه اين هي
حقيقه للاسف يعني للاسف
ما ادري والله انا زعلتي عايزه اعرف
الحاجه دي يعني اه يعني صراحه
الى قضيه ضد التنمر المراه السودانيه بشكل
عام انت لجاتي بعد هذه الواقعه لنخبه من
الاستشاريين والقانونيين القضاء على
التنمر حدثين اكثر عن ذلك
فعلا انا
لجات فعلا انا حولت القضيه بدل ما انه انا
افتح قضيه ضد الصفحات الاساءت لي او افتح
قضيه غادي يجيها معينه انا غلطت انه افتح
القضيه الا وهي لا للتنمر ضد المراه
يعني فالله صلى الله عليه وسلم بالغوالين
فانا عايزه اخذ الغبيه
نزل حاجه ثانيه انه التنمر ضد المراه
الابيض لها حاجه شايعه جدا الايام دي في
الميديا فحاليا يعني مع الاخ منذ العوض
وبعض المستشعلين التابعه والمحامين ان شاء
الله القضيه حتى اخذ مسائل ثانيه طيب خلود
يعني على الطبيعه للي ما بعرفك وحكى معك
على الطبيعه او على الهواء مباشره كان
شويه شكد قصه اللدغه هل هي خاصها بالتمثيل
تلزوم الشخصيه الدراميه ولا لدغه طبيعيه
وحقيقيه انا اليوم تاكدت شو بدك تقولي
للناس الله يسعدك
الله يسعدك يا رب اللدغه بتحكي اساعدك
الجدل في الفتله الاخيره لانه انا لم
اتولد للصغير
حادث بتحتال اختفيت فتله من الميديا فلما
جيت الناس كانت مستغربه والله كان عندي
خفيف فجاه كده اللي حصل عشان انا قلت لهم
والله يا جماعه يعني الحمد لله يعني انا
راضيه باطلاء ربنا وارحل حاليا ما بامثل
شكرا
بسبب الحادث الذي عرضته عندي مشكله في
الله طيب فقط النوه هي خلود انه مسلسل
زوجان ولكن كان اول ظهور تمثيلي لك وحظي
ابي شهادات النقاد الفنيه شكرا جزيلا على
تخصيص صباح العربيه بهذا الظهور اهي
اول ظهور بالنسبه للكوميديا لكن عندي
عمليه كان قبل كده خلال الميديا وان شاء
الله عندي عمل غادم مع الاستاذ هيثم امين
اسمه ولد الماكس رمضان يعني زي ما بقول
المثل عندنا اول دخوله شمعه على طول يا
خلود شكرا لك خلود ابو بكر